じゃ、育成とは何かって言うと、目標達成
の能力を開発する。
フィールドトレーニングオーダーと言うん
ですけど、同行で一緒に現場に連れてって
もらって、どうしても自分はこれを
成し遂げていきたい。そういう風に本人が
願望があれば育ちます。青木サ市の人生
哲学100回聞いたら豊かになる話
。
今回はですね、新入社員の育成ステップについてお話伺えればと思ってます。
はい。アチーブメントでも3
年給料の、ま、5
倍のりを稼げる人材になることが、ま、1
つの基準であるとお伝えしてると思うんですけれども、ま、そのレベルまで育ててくためには、ま、どう育成していけばいいのかということについて教えていただけますでしょうか?
[音楽]
実はこの採用と育成というのは支質、やっぱり支出の高い人を採用できるかどうか、これによってその後の育成のプ
プロセスって変わるんですよ。ま、育成
っていうのは具体的に言うとその人自身の
マインド、心構えというか、え、仕事に
対する捉え方、向き合い方、これは、ま、
本当に10人問色なんですよね。ですから
私はよく、ま、社員に対して4つの地信と
いうのを、ま、提供すると会社に対する
絶対の地震、そして職業に対する絶対の
地震そして商品自分が扱っている商品に
対する絶対の地震、そして自分に対する
絶対の自信、ま、この4つの地震をまず
確立すると、ま、特に営業教育の場合は
コンサルタントでもですね、パーソナル
コンサルティング部、組織
コンサルティング部と営業部分も色々ある
んですけれども、特に最初の段階はこの
パーソナルコンサルティング部に、ま、
配属される人に関してはこの4つの地震、
これは、あ、いわゆるマインドですよね。
どちらかというと、それから、ま、
ノーハウ、ま、ナレッジの領域っていうの
は実はマニュアルがありましたね。成功の
指針というマニュアル。このマニュアルは
もう私が長年にわって、え、自分自身が
プロの職業人として特に営業という世界、
それから、ま、このコンサルタントという
仕事の中で、ま、我々の仕事の根感にある
、え、ま、成功哲学、また選択、ま、そう
いった様々なメソロジー、それを、ま、
具体的にどういう風に、え、まず自分の
ものにしていくのかから始まり仕事の進め
方ですよね。ですからこのまずは
マニュアルの中にそういうもう具体的な
仕事の進め方、手順方法内容全部まず記憶
しなければいけない。覚え
るっていうことですね。うん。あとは、ま
、SNSをね、中でもいろんなそういう
仕組みを使って、え、覚えることもあり
ますし、ま、会社の中には色々
イントラネットということで車内の
いろんなそういう情報が整理されてますの
で、差しだけじゃなくて、そういう様々な
仕組みの中で、ま、覚えていく。あとは
会社の中での仕事の進め方というか、
例えばご契約いただいてどういう風に、え
、きちっとそのドキュメンテーションどう
いう風なステップで残していくのかとか
全部そういうのがもう明確になってんです
よ。分かりやすく。で、それをまず覚える
。で、あとはスキルですよね。3つ目。
マインド、ノーハウスキル。やっぱり技術
の習得まで、ま、一応私は早ければ2年、
遅くても3年で、ま、報酬の5倍のりを
稼げる人間になると、ま、そこから逆算し
た育成をしていくんですけれど、ま、うち
の場合は初人級も非常に決して低くはなく
、ま、低いか高いかは人それぞれの捉え方
ですけど、一応33万という、え大学卒業
して新卒社員にそれだけの報酬出しますの
でこれをマインドノーハウスキルをスキル
は1番最後ですよね。身につくまではでも
そこまではしっかりと2人三脚であの
メンターのように上司がついてですね。
そして2人三脚で育成をして、で、うちの
人事効果って非常にユニークで、下の人間
を育成できる人間が上に上がるという人事
制度にしてるんですよ。だ、育成の過程で
組織は発展し、育成の過程で、ま、業績は
伸びていく。で、育成とは何かって言うと
、目標達成の能力を開発する。つまり自分
の部下の目標達成が自分の目標達成になる
人事制度にしてるんですね。ま、そういう
仕組みを整えながら、ま、約3年で、ま、
セミナーのアシスタントをしたり、それ
から、ま、上司のアシスタントをしたり、
そしてフィールドトレーニングオーダーと
言うんですけど、同行で一緒に現場に連れ
てってもらって、そして、え、上司の
プレゼンテーションをしっかりと見る。ま
、今もZoomでプレゼンテーションを
するっていうこと多いですけれども、その
場合もやっぱり横に動しながらそれを吸収
する。で、あとは今度は自分がやってみる
。その時は上司が横について。で、ま、
そういうことを繰り返しながら、ま、少し
ずつ育成されていくということなんですね
。ですから、まあ、今大体育成のステップ
、マインド面、ノーハウ面、スキル面大体
のところ大きく伝えました。もう本当に
細かく話をするとこれだけで少なくとも半
日は必要なぐらいすごく細部にわって
私たちは考えてるわけです。ですから、
あの、よく新卒は使えないっていう経営者
の人いるんですけど、そうではなくて、
それはあの、ま、ナレッチマネジメントを
含めたそういうしっかりとした地在の管理
も含めその教えられる情報伝達の仕組みが
整ってないだけであって、支出さえ
しっかりした人を採用できれば支出かける
環境×本人の選択、この方程式ですから、
ま、最終的にはその本人の選択というのは
やっぱり明確な
目的内発的同期付けが起こってどうしても
自分はこれを成し遂げていきたい。そう
いう風に本人が願望があれば育ちます。で
も本人の願望が弱い。つまりマインド面で
ネガティブであったりなんだろう。その
自信がない。どうしてもそうすると恐れに
支配されて回避モチベーションが働いて
しまう。そういうケースの場合はもう支出
の面でできる限り前向きな人材を採用して
企業の環境の中でその人材を育てていく。
ま、そして3年経ったら1年前の、ま、
コンサルタントにするとだ、普通一般的に
は10年って言われてんですよ。でもうち
は非常に早いです。っていうのは商品その
ものも私がもう長年研究してきたその営業
においてもセールスマネジメントにおいて
もま、マネージメント全般のプログラムを
色々開発をして、え、願望実現目標達成の
プログラムとかそのプログラム化したもの
を具体的にファシリテーションしながら身
につけていただくフォローをしていき
ながらお客様と一緒に成長していく。
ま、そういう仕組みを整えているので、ま、
年で大体みんな例外なく給料の5
倍の付加価値を乱せる人材に成長すると、ま、そういうことなんですね。早い人はもう入社して
1年でそうなります。
ありがとうございます。
[音楽]
なんかこのマインドとナジとスキルはなんかまずどれから身につけた方がいいとかっていうなんか順番ってあったりするんでしょうか?やっぱりこれは同時平行なんですけど、
番最後に身につくのはスキルですよね。マインドっていうのはね、やっぱり支質的なものもあるんですよ。支質というよりも質って言った方がいい。
だからその人の持って生まれたものもある
し、もう入社前のどういう家庭環境で育っ
てきたか、あえてネガティブなものの考え
方をする人は採用する必要はないですよね
。で、大体もう小学校、中学校、高校、
特に高校時代ってのはすごく大事で、この
高校時代に突破体験をどれぐらい持ってる
かってことですよね。そして、ま、一応
大学まで行って、大学っていうのは本来は
例えばその弁護士になるには法律を学ぶと
か医者になるには医学を学ぶとか本来は
専門知識を身につけていくのが大学の本来
の姿ですよね。だけど一般共有を身につけ
て社会に出てくるとなると、ま、偏差値の
高い大学の方が確かにベースとなる
ロジカルシンキングだとか確率的には高い
かもしれない。だけど基本的にはそのお
受験の目標達成をしてきたっていう意味で
は評価しますけれども実は仕事をして成果
出す人っていうのは先ほどもちょっと述べ
た心構いが本当に重要で私はあの以前その
仕事のできる人、仕事のできない人って
いうことを研修であの皆さんに発表して
もらってホワイトボードにバーっと
書き出したんですよ。で、これはメンタル
ですか?スキルですか?分けていったら8
割型メンタルになるんですよ。仕事に
対する姿勢が前向きとかね。8割がね、
メンタルなんですよ。だからやっぱりその
心構えってね、本来会社に入る前に本当は
家庭教育とかいろんなところで身につけて
くるのが望ましいですよね。ただ中には
会社に入って本当に良くなる人もいます
から、あの何をしたいかっていうことが不
明確な時ってモチベーション低いんですよ
。でもこれをしたいというものが見えて
見つかってきてあ、ここで自分のキャリア
は形成できるなっていう見通しを持ったら
人は働き物に変わります。それとやっぱり
ね、前のYouTubeでも言ってるん
ですけど、物信
両面経済的にも精神的にも豊かになれる
見通しがその会社にあるかどうか。これは
マインド面ですごく重要。ま、
アチューメントはおかげ様で、ま、
グレイトプレスワークの世界150カ国に
色々この調査している、ま、働き買いある
会社で、ま、一応ベストカンパニー10年
入ってますし、ま、結果的に、ま、今回ね
、グランプリも取ったんですけど、昨年も
その前も準グランプリでした。でもこれ実
はそれを目指して仕事してるんではなくて
、5つの基本的欲求が満たされる職場環境
、生存、愛と所属、力、自由、楽しみ。だ
から社員をどうしたら幸せにできるかって
いうことを考えて本気で関わっていくので
、経済的にも精神的にも報われる。そこに
やっぱりやりがいが生まれると。今ね、
若い方々のマネジメントに悩んでいる経営
者非常に多いって聞きました。つまりその
やりがいということすらも何か何かこう
なんて言うのかな?コントロールされてる
ようなそういう受け止め方をする若い人が
いるらしいです。うちはでも全てそれは
本人の心の中の状態なのでだ環境そのもの
はしっかり整えてあげてやっぱりこの人材
教育の好きな人材を採用して一緒になって
育て上げてまずは拠店長に育て最終的には
トレーナーに育てそして経営者に育てて
いくもしくはルートが違えばそれこそ企画
の分野だとかでも企画の世界はもう特に支
字頭が良くないと入社してから頭が良くな
るっていうのはね、よっぽどの人じゃない
と難しいですね。やっぱりベースがあり
ます。支質8割ぐらいかな。で、あとは
環境で伸ばす。ま、うちはそれを育成と
いう言葉で使いますけど伸ばす力があるん
だと思うんですよね
[音楽]
。そうですね。だから、ま、ちょっと今
触れなかったんですけれども、大前提は
迎入れた以上は家族の一員、ファミリーの
一になる。それぐらいの気持ちで入社した
以上は1人前に育て上げるという
コミットメントを上司がまず持つってこと
だと思うんだよね。だ、上司の決意、絶対
この人を1人前の職業人に育てるんだと
いう、そういう決意がまず大事だと思うん
ですよ。会社としての、ま、あり方、社員
に多くを求めるよりも会社として、ま、
親子で言うなら親ですよね。親が子に対し
てどれだけ誠実に真心を持ってだから
ちゃんとそういうお互いが向き合って新入
社員に対しては3年でここまで育てるぞと
いう会社が姿勢を持ってそしてあとは
マインドノーハウスキルこの3つを
しっかりと時間をかけて育てていく
関わり合いの内というものを大切にし
ながらあの良いところ長所神殿法ね、
伸ばしてあげてもらえればきっと人は育つ
と思いますよ。じゃあ是非ね、今の私の、
ま、メッセージいいなと思ったら、え、
チャンネル登録も是非お願いしたいです。
そしてコメント欄にもね、是非感じたこと
コメントいただければありがたいです。
また次回のYouTubeでお見り
ましょう
[音楽]
。前味、中味、後味。ま、前味っていうの
は、あの、お客様と面談して最初の
いわゆるクラッチ合わせと言って
コミュニケーションをどうやって取るのか
とかがフロントトークと言って、え、最初
の段階でどういう風にお客様にこう必要性
であるとか、え、ま、課題、これを特定し
ていくっていうところの質問技法ですよね
。え、そういうこととかで、あと中味って
いうのはプレゼンテーションそのものなん
ですよ。説明の仕方、進め方、そういう
ことを具体的にも本当に分かりやすく
マニュアルとして表現しています。そして
、ま、プレゼンテーションで、え、最終的
にクロージング、反論処理、そして
クロージング、クロージングってのは制約
ですよね。契約をいいたところで普通はあ
、仕事が終わるとみんな思うんですよ。
セールスに携わってる人間は。だと前味
中味しか話してないでしょ。この後から
始まるんですよ。つまり真の営業というの
はここからが始まりなんです。つまり納品
後味ですよね。しっかりとお客様に対して
、え、この説明の段階でお伝えしたことが
きちっとその、ま、うちの仕事で言うと
技術の習得まで退得までフォローしていき
ます。そして本当にこう予想外価値ここ
までアチュウメントさんフォローするのか
というような最後感動を与えて初めて納品
官僚感動そしてその感動から実はですね
一生の協力者が生まれます。そしてそこ
から口込みが起こるわけです。これが1番
最初のまた前味、中味、後味。この連鎖
ですよね。だ、それがもうどんどん
どんどん絶間なく続いていくので、まさに
こう富士山の末広がりのように毎年毎年
顧客数が増え、毎年毎年実は正社員は
220名ですけれども、外部の満足したお
客様が口込みでどんどんどんどん動いて
くださる。これが、ま、まさに前味、中味
、後味の感動を与えますから、本当に満足
したお客様は最高の協力者になって
くださって、ま、38年間今日までですね
、ま、おかげ様で発展反映を続けてきたと
、ま、こういうことなんです。
決して負けない経営だ。まず経営者自身が
お金よりも仕事の内容をそのものに
惚れ込んでるかどうかです。